quand les gramounes fait la musique
c'est l'ambiance des bals la poussière
qui revient au goût du jour et c'est
bernadette ladauge chef d'orchestre
d'une après midi de musique qui a donné
le la de cette manifestation et nous
adrian s'y retrouver nous avons
longtemps
ne dira pas quand on les voit encore
des gramounes venus nombreux dans
l'espace réduit malgré une petite pluie
fine une mise dans l'ambiance avec un
orchestre composé d'une génération de
musiciens avec le non moins célèbre
narmine ducap et bien entendu la famille
ladauge et le gras les vieux ses galons
temps qu'ils mettent toujours autant
l'ambiance
avant ces mamans à côté papa
papa
et si bernadette ladauge est là c'est
bien sûr pour transmettre la mémoire de
notre patrimoine musical avec notamment
les danses qui avait cours à une
certaine époque dans notre île grand
romancier
fêter la musique avec des jeunes mais
avant tout avec des moins jeunes mais
qui n'ont rien à envier en matière de
déhanchés à la nouvelle génération pour
nassimah dindar la musique les talents
doivent émerger quel que soit l'âge
et jamie bell la belle a
tout au long de l'année
nous voulons faire un char que cette
fête elles soient plantés dans les
écoles dans les clubs de troisième âge
pour que les potentialités et la
découverte au fond pas de la culture
musicale créole qui est aussi une
culture musicale universelle avec notre
propre métissage
réunionnais de la musique avec magna
à ceux qui nous on a pensé à
tout m
j'ai envie
une journée tout en bonheur tout en
musique dans un cadre magnifique celui
de l'espace régler une troisième
jeunesse qui s'amusent et qui fait
honneur à la tradition en continuant à
perpétuer le rythme de notre bon vieux
sega
à
avant
pas moi à
là